[Music] Good morning, sir. Please
introduce yourself
briefly. I'm Olivier, 51 years old, a
lawyer.
So, generally, I cheat, but
until recently, I was increasing my fees.
Now I'm decreasing them. Well, it's been 25
years. The reality is that it's been 25 years,
so I've dedicated my practice from the
beginning to information technologies, and I'm trying my
best to keep it that way.
What type of cases do you handle? Well,
we deal with cases
in the field of
information technology. As I said, let's
say it revolves around three
main themes: counterfeiting, poor workmanship,
and what we used to call
computer fraud. Now it's called
cybercrime. You're the lawyer for a
case that's known online as the
Bluetooth case.
Can you tell us a little more about it
in detail? It's a ruling that was
handed down by the Paris Court of Appeal
recently, and it caused quite a
stir because after we
obtained the acquittal of the defendant...  Bluetooth,
before the Créteil criminal court, is
appealing to uphold the decision and
convict the defendant, Bluetooth, for fraudulently remaining
in an
automated data processing system.
To summarize the case very schematically, in short,
Bluetooth is
accused, after a simple
Google search, of having accessed
documents from a state agency (which I won't name)
in the field of
public health. They claim to have accessed these
documents, then taken them
and published
press articles based on reports or
presentations made in ANSES
working groups. The specific offense for which
Bluetooth was charged, and which led to
the conviction by the
Paris Court of Appeal, is what is called
the offense of fraudulently remaining in an
automated data processing system.
This is article 3231 of the penal code,
which carries a maximum penalty
of two years in prison and a
€30,000 fine.
The individuals involved are therefore...  Uh, uh,
guilty of this offense. Well, uh, we
are now before the
Court of Cassation. We have filed an appeal and will
submit our brief in
the coming days. And uh, we hope to have
this ruling overturned.
Tell me, was Google
prosecuted in this case? Was
Google notified? Was Google
informed? What can you
tell us then? Was Google prosecuted? No,
Google,
indeed, with its robots, had
identified a link that led to its
content, which was made available to the
public, probably even certainly,
since it was later recognized
by mistake on Lancess's part. But
Google was not prosecuted, that's certain. Notified, probably.
Apart from the
online outcry, I
think Google wasn't questioned, doesn't
appear in the file, not even as a
witness or interviewed as a witness by the
police. In this case, it was the
Central Directorate of Internal Intelligence (
DCRI) that conducted the
police investigation, given the identity of the
complainant. So,
neither  He wasn't prosecuted or questioned, at least not
officially, and his name isn't
in the file. He may have been a defendant, but did
the judge raise the possibility that
Google might have also copied the
files to its servers in the United States? That's
a point that was
n't considered. Google wasn't
present at the hearings, because, as you know,
in criminal
court hearings, the court reviews the
investigation in certain ways. In this case, that question wasn't
addressed because Google
wasn't present or
summoned, following the logic of the prosecution, which
pursued Bluetooth. Well, indeed, these were
questions that could have been
asked. What does your client
risk? He
risks the
maximum penalties provided for the offense he's
accused of, which, as I said, are two years of
imprisonment and a
€30,000 fine. That's the
maximum. Well, these are theoretical penalties, insofar as, in this case,
and this is somewhat what bothers
us about
Bluetooth, even if...  Technically, it didn't prevent the prosecutor's office from
pursuing the case. You don't have a
victim; you have a complainant
initially, but that year he didn't file a
civil suit at either of the two
hearings in the court or the Court of Appeal.
In any case, he didn't file a civil suit in the court,
so naturally, not in the Court
of Appeal either. There's no public prosecutor, to my
knowledge. For example,
public health issues are handled by
this agency. One might have imagined that
public health issues would arise
in this case, in the
documents that were found by
Bluetooth. That's not the case either.
And so, in the end, we
have a question of principle, or a
position, a stance that has been taken by
the prosecutor's office against
Bluetooth, which, again, is a matter of mindset.
In this case,
a criminal investigation must be conducted. We are
shocked. And indeed, this was
said, notably by my client. He saw
a certain relentlessness, and this raises
questions regarding his own
status. Even though he is not a
professional journalist, he has written about
cases.  Sensitive cases, for example,
the
Amesis case and the sale, let's say, of
electronic surveillance tools to
Gaddafi's Libya. Eagle, you're talking about Eagle,
yes, and so he wrote about
sensitive subjects, and obviously we can't help but
compare
this situation to what he's experiencing
in the legal proceedings. You know,
for a person, an individual, a private citizen, to
go through
legal proceedings, especially criminal proceedings, it's
an ordeal, and it's an ordeal that
lasts over time. This case has been going on for over
a year now
for Bluetooth, and so obviously it's
something difficult to go through, something that
leaves its mark on your
life. You don't come out of a criminal case the same as you
were before. And so, this
ordeal, do you feel it's
a scapegoat, or is it rather a
lack of training for our judges?
Or when we hear that the
judge, or the prosecutor, says, "Google,
Google," well, yes, that's indeed what happened
in
court.  The issue didn't
arise in the correctional court, but it so happens that there were
indeed
transcripts of the hearings. I was there, and
I can confirm their veracity. Two
journalists present were
indeed shocked, struck, astonished.
Indeed, you mentioned
the use of the word "googler," meaning "login"
for login. Anyway, there were a
number of words spoken
by the
reporting judge, who presents the case in open
court. He's the one who
studied the file before the court...
ultimately, the court of appeals. This showed, let's say,
a certain
distance from my knowledge of
the internet. Well, perhaps my
knowledge isn't mine to judge.
Now, I've already answered these
questions when they were asked of me. It's
true, I admit, my knowledge
was quite evident, but that doesn't change the fact that
we don't ask a
judge who deals with
building law to be a bricklayer, nor do we ask him
to be a geek when he
deals with technology.  The information
is true, perhaps the Ministry of
Justice should make a bit more of an
effort with regard to magistrates because
perhaps the difference, particularly with the
police services where they were
specialized and
professionalized very early on, is perhaps more pronounced than in
the
judiciary. Perhaps there is an
effort to be made, but that doesn't prevent a
court and magistrates from
ruling. That's what they did. Did
your client receive support from
professional journalists? Did
your client have any support? Did
he receive a lot of support? Well, not from the
organized profession, let's say from
organized journalists, not from the profession as far as I
know. Now, we've had
reactions after the press, let's say from the organized profession, from the profession.
I'm
thinking in particular of
Miapart and its director who spoke
publicly about the
conviction. Yes, indeed, there was a lot
of support, but we ca
n't say that it wasn't from the
organized profession, not from the profession as
you said.
I have a question for you
concerning  The military programming law
—can you
give me your opinion? Listen, this
might surprise me, but this
issue with your
military programming law of December 18, 2013, which was
followed a few weeks later
by a law on glocalization—
uh, without judicial oversight—uh,
the various issues—
Google, 100% judicial oversight, but with
oversight from the Prime
Minister's office—so for the
military programming laws, indeed,
a person appointed by the Prime
Minister in coordination with an
independent administrative authority—
I never remember the
exact name of this authority—but
which effectively oversees
security intercepts—I'll
speak under your supervision—do
you think the
military programming law is an
extension of administrative wiretapping?
Well, first of all, you said yes, so it's
an extension of
administrative wiretapping, but we've gone beyond the
stage of simply listening; that's the
problem. It's no longer the service that's going to
tap into the line and listen to what's
happening, or even
intercept what's going on.  The airwaves are clear, Pino's
simple, which is finished. So, we're now
in the data collection phase,
in the data capture phase.
Data collection, as the law states, means we're going to
search for data from service providers, from
technical intermediaries. We're going to search for
all kinds of data. It could be emails,
electronic mail, it could be
banking information, it could be passwords. That's what it's all about. So, what do we do
with
that? When we have a suspicion—because that's
the reality, that's the
trigger—when we have a suspicion about
someone, well, we investigate, and we
investigate, provided, of course, that there are
a number of subjects that fall under
military programming, such as
international terrorism, national security, but
also the defense of
France's economic and cultural heritage. But there's also,
meaning
organized counterfeiting and, in particular,
tax fraud, also organized. So,
we have a fairly varied set of offenses
in the end, and as soon as these offenses
are identified...  When
suspicions are administratively directed at a person—
I'll use a strong analogy—
the police now have the
legal power to rummage
through someone's computer, open
email accounts, take
addresses, passwords, and
bank details,
all with a level of control that, in my opinion, is
quite chaotic and almost
nonexistent, offering no guarantees to the
citizen. In France, we implemented something similar, 10
years late, 12 years late, a kind of
mini-sister
to the
American Patriot Act, which was passed three
weeks before, after, the
September 11, 2001 attacks, in
October 2001, by the Bush administration with
unanimous support from Congress, both
Republican and Democratic senators. You
see this as a
danger in the fight against
international terrorism? It's legitimate, it's in
everyone's interest. This is
n't a virtual threat; it's
a real threat, and even if it
's digital, the danger I see is
twofold: the
absence of...  The near absence of
citizen guarantees is also a concern in the United States
today. I
remind you that in 2012, the
US Congress voted to extend the Patriot Act for a number
of years—I believe five
years—and a
Democratic senator was the first to
introduce an amendment requesting
more guarantees for citizens. Do
you have his name? I don't have it offhand,
but I can
give it to you. Well, this amendment was
rejected, but it was proposed.
So, firstly, there's a lack of
citizen guarantees. Secondly, and this is particularly
glaring in the United States,
the NSA, when it implements the
Prism program, is in the same vein as the
Patriot Act and
military programming. The message
it sends to the tech giants and
those who signed this program in
2007—Microsoft was the
first to sign, then Google, Facebook,
Apple—nine
companies in total, all with Verizon. What do
these tech giants say?
Monitor the population, I'll give you
the white paper. You can't tell
these people to limit their
surveillance and at the same time want them to
give you all the data
you collect on people
I'll designate. Is this a
government initiative to broadly identify and
map its population
because its population is
becoming a risk to the stability
and sovereign power of the state?
So, I'll answer you in two parts.
I'd say one, the road to hell is paved with
good intentions. Okay, good intentions mean
the fight against
international terrorism, I have no problem with that. But
the second floor of the
building is below the
NSA, below that the DGSI, below that all
the state services that
legitimately fight against
tax fraud, counterfeiting, and
so on. They still listen to
journalists, they seize phone records. There are
computers on the floor
below. You have Google, you have
Facebook, which monitor the
population, but in a way that...  It's getting tighter and tighter,
and they're not doing it for
the goals I just mentioned.
They're doing predictive marketing. They're
capable of telling you that when
you get up in the morning, you'll
scratch your right ear
after drinking a glass of
hotel water. I mean, they're going very, very
far these days with
predictions, and that's why they do it: it's
for business, it's to make
money. And these companies
have set up a business model that,
at least implicitly, has been accepted by
the NSA and all the
police departments. And when you
present this observation to me, a
question comes to mind: isn't this perhaps
a
betrayal of our
judicial system, of our judges, to protect
our fellow citizens? Or is it simply
incompetence? To put it bluntly,
they're completely out of touch with
the law, which
also applies to information systems,
of course, and through negligence, they let it happen.
So, advised by lobbyists who
know the extent of lobbying in
legislative work, so for
you, is this perhaps
a resignation, or is it simply no? I would
n't say a resignation, I wouldn't even say
incompetence, no, not even that. I would say a
lack of
vision, a lack of understanding, a
lack of perspective on the issue.
Yes, because we are in the process of
implementing a surveillance system like this,
but it has never existed in our
society. I wrote an article on my
blog called "Great-Grandfather
and Great-Grandson Say No to
Military Programming," and what am
I saying? We are in a system where your
great-grandfather leaves
his house, goes to
his bookseller, his baker, and you
have the police saying, "
Bookseller and baker, you are going to note the
times this
gentleman enters and leaves, and when he speaks,
you are going to note it, and you are going to
note the price he pays you, how much he charges you."
Pay how much he pays you and so on.
Now in a
surveillance system, he pays you if he sweated
when he... completely, completely.
We're in a system like that
today. The baker is interested
in doing this because,
as you say, he can map his clientele. It's
in his business
model, and there you have it, that's his system. What's
totally normal is that
we encourage him in this system
by setting up these companies.
So you're telling me, to
summarize so trivially, that the baker
becomes an auxiliary police officer without
legitimacy? Absolutely. I call that
a substitute. You call that an
auxiliary because I'm an
auxiliary to the justice system as a
lawyer, so I have respect for the
word auxiliary, less for the word supplementary.
So I say rather a supplementary.
But yes, but that's the
Prism program. I recently attended the
annual dinner of an organization
in the field of CLUT computing. What's it called? What's it
called?
Euroclad France, which is a very good
organization—I'm its Secretary
General, so I'm not going to criticize it—
but it's true that it's
a very
interesting organization. Things happen there, and
we had a dinner where we
invited, among others, BPI, the
public investment bank, and, well,
a manager of a very large investment fund in
California and Silicon Valley—I can't remember
the name—
and this person said
something that struck me. He said, "
Today, with the
Prism affair, we don't want to hear about the government anymore. In
California, they've done us too much harm,
too much harm, or betrayed us. They've done us too much
harm with the NSA, with Prism, and so on,
or perhaps betrayed us too much in terms of
trust. We're talking about this because there's no
business without trust, and you
know, in the United States, it's
ultimately an attack on business that gets the
strongest reaction." And I thought to myself,
this remark...  It shows
that nothing will change, that since Prism
and Snowon, nothing will change.
That is to say, it's
too easy to blame only the
American government. The
American government is fighting against
terrorism, and again, that
seems perfectly legitimate to me. It's defending
its citizens against a
real threat, and I have no problem with that.
But through its actions, its
behavior, and its lack of vision,
it's ultimately implementing a
surveillance system that it doesn't implement itself, a system implemented
by
others. And if these others, these
companies, these web giants, don't do
their own thing—and can they,
since that means changing their
business model, changing
their economic model?—I remind you
that the economic model of Facebook and
Google,
contrary to appearances (to
take the latter), isn't about creating a
search engine or publishing
free
office software. We know very well that it's
the advertising and
marketing market that
interests them. Well, these companies have a
business that demands...  Regarding
the surveillance of populations, and I
find it regrettable that
state services don't limit, and on the contrary,
encourage this system, I'm going to ask you
two last questions. The first
will be your perception as a
citizen, perhaps as a father, perhaps
also as a
lawyer: what's happening? Where are we now, where are we
going? Long-term question, but
I think we're currently experiencing
a tsunami-like process. That is to say,
the Snowden affair, which dates back only a few years—and
I call it the Snowden affair, but
actually I don't usually call it the
Snowden affair because for me it's
the St. Wind prism. Yes, so, in addition, but
for me, the problem isn't
Edward Snowden, the problem is the prism.
So I believe it's a tsunami. A
tsunami happens; first there's a
shockwave, and
then we have the effects, the
symptoms. In the summer of
2013, the clients of all these companies that had
signed with the
NSA since June...  Since
June 6, 2013, an article in the Washington Post,
followed by The Guardian the next day, these customers,
subscribers,
members can say, "These companies have betrayed me,"
and that means that
trust in these
companies is indeed compromised, tainted, breached.
So, if this
trust is tainted—and we have,
for me, warning signs
practically daily—we see the number
of Facebook members decreasing. The
purchases of this company, in my opinion, still
testify to a
panic, an awareness of
things. But they cannot evolve, cannot
change their business model; it's
the heart of their
reality. Well, if this trust
continues, this distrust
continues to increase, then it is
society, indeed
the State, that risks suffering, and the
digital networks and the State. It's
a new anonymization industry
that will be established, which will cause
the soybeans to...  To become anonymous or
leave social networks, even if it's still a very small
minority movement
today, you meet people who
tell you, "Don't send me emails," when
you leave social networks, you're
considered suspicious. Yes, indeed, it's still very much the case
today. It's
normal; it's a
very small minority behavior and goes against the grain. Okay, one
last question:
if you had the opportunity to give
advice to the younger generation
listening to us, what advice would you give them
on the internet, like a message in a bottle? I would
tell them: learn to
be the strategist of your identity. Your
identity is your freedom.
And so, learn to be the strategist
of your
identity. Thank you very much. Thank
you.
The idea of ​​the Trilateral Commission comes
from David Rockefeller 35 years ago. He
brought together a few dozen Europeans,
Americans, and Japanese, saying to them, "
Listen, we have problems in common,
for
example, relations with China, for
example, relations with
what was at the time
the USSR. Let's try to have..."
Common positions that are in the
general interest... I don't know if an hour with
a class of Sciences Po Master's students is
a representative sample. One thing
I'm sure of is that in the last
10 days,
5 people have come to see me saying, "
Hey, you know what? I quit
Facebook." And for many, they told me it was because of
a conversation we had
today. What
I'd like, what would be really great from everyone, is for us to start
creating
alternative products that allow us to maintain
network neutrality and
net neutrality in case the others
shut down and
Jean-Manuel's optimism doesn't materialize. There you go.